you think Martin Sheen credits um the
Martin Sheen connection that's kind of a
long story
because Emilio and Martin were over in
Spain doing some pre-production and
raising some money
at the very same time I was they were
like in Santiago literally days before I
was so I contacted them let them know I
was making this documentary and we were
both gonna film around the same time and
as it turns out they had to delay their
shooting until the fall of 2009 and I
was shooting spring 2009 so we shot and
we immediately put together this 23
minute trailer which was to raise money
and show potential funders and I sent it
to Martin and he loved it and he showed
it to Emilio and Martin later told me
that Emilio showed it to some of his
cast and crew members to really give
them an idea of what it's like to be on
the Camino and so that was very sweet
and then we kind of stayed in touch
and obviously Emilio came out the way
came out way earlier than them we did
and there was a point in time when they
were missing some shots and they were
gonna license some footage but then they
ended up going back and reshooting and
so so we're in touch and talking now and
then and what happened was they did a
kind of a pre-screening at the at
Georgetown University it was this huge
screening it was like five hundred it
was sort of a gala event and there was
you know the Spanish ambassador and all
these people even some of the Spanish
royalty came to it and so during the Q&A
after the screening I was there because
I was part of a pilgrimage conference
and this the screening was part of this
pilgrimage conference that I was
presenting at and so during this Emmaus
big screening people were doing Q&A so I
stood up and said hi it's Lydia from the
Camino documentary because they both
knew what I sounded like but they they
knew who I was but they didn't
what I look like and Martin just went
off and he just was so kind in he just
immediately was saying that Lydia's made
this great documentary and she's run out
of money so if anybody has a bag of
money they really should give it to her
it's a brilliant documentary and it's
real people and to me that was really
one of the most kind gestures someone
could do in the screening of their own
film to go on and on and try and help
somebody else so that's why I helped I
mean I thanked Martin and Emilia has
been quite kind to I we were
negotiations with a distributor that
they used and so he kind of has been
letting me know how that worked out for
them and recommending them and so
they've been and I'm extremely grateful
to the way because because of that film
there's so many more people that are
interested in the Camino and want to
know more and then they come to our film
so we were very blessed to have them
come out a couple years before us
you